the cars the cars are going gay Ford
Motors put out this ad and they put this
out for pride month already here you
[Music]
go what is the obsession with marketing
everything towards gay trans whatever
and the gay and trans have nothing to do
with each other they're actually Arch
enemies sort of like Optimus Prime and
Megatron I'll rip out your Optics gays
and trans should not like each other
because the trans want to chop off the
genitals of the gays let's put that
aside for a second why would you be
marketing to a very Niche audience and
who what gay person is walking in when
you want to buy a car and you know okay
so you're sitting there you're looking
at two trucks well which one of these
trucks is gayer